هو احد الاشخاص اللي بيشتغلوا مع ماسك من
سنوات في عشرين او في 2003 انضم لسبيس اكس
وحاليا هو الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
من سنه كمان بيساعدوا في تويتر والساعات
الماضيه اسم ستيف متداول جدا في الاخبار
والسبب تقارير بتقول انه ماسك خلاص اختاره
علشان يخلفوا في رئاسه تويتر ماسك لو
مفكرين من اشهر اعلن انه راح يتنحى عن هذا
المنصب ويدور على شخص مجنون كفايه عشان
يتولى الاداره ومن كم اسبوع انسال عن
الموضوع في قمه الحكومات في دبي انه من
متى او انه متى حيتنحى عن رئاسه تويتر
فقال انه قريبا وغالبا قبل اخر السنه ومن
وقتها والتساؤلات شغاله عن هويه رئيس
تويتر الجديد التقارير الحاليه بترجح انه
هو الشخص المختار وبتقول انه صار له سنه
شغال مع ماسك عن قرب في تويتر وبتسميه
كمان مهندس التسريحات
تويتر تلقوا مكالمات من ديفيس قبل طرح
خلالها عليهم اسئله عن الموظفين
والمتميزين من الموظفين المتميزين تحديدا
والاداء العام للموظفين وفكروا انه يعني
المدراء بيسرقوا عشان المكافات لكن يعني
هم بيسال عشان المكافات لكن اتضح انه لا
انه هو كان بيسال كده عشان وقتها كانت
فتره التسريح من الوظائف على العموم خلينا
نرجع كمان في بعض المعلومات اللي طلعت انه
كمان ماسك كلف وبتخفيض 500 مليون دولار من
التكاليف لكن اشتغل على تخفيض مليار دولار
عن طريق انهاء بعض العقود مع شركات خارجيه
والتفاوض على البعض الاخر هذا غير انه هو
بينام في المكتب في بقر الشركه وكل هذه
الاشياء خله التكهنات بانه هو اللي راح
يكون الرئيس التنفيذي القادم للتويتر
[موسيقى]